der schaum auf das nächste thema soll um
die berufliche weiterbildung gehen und
es geht noch einmal ums kurzarbeitergeld
ein gesetzentwurf arbeit von morgen
gesetz abgekürzt
zum einen der punkte weiterbildung also
die bundesagentur für arbeit
die soll zuschüsse zu lehrgangskosten
und blödeln beispielsweise erhöhen oder
auch in verbindung mit kurzarbeit soll
weiterbildungen bei den unternehmen
erleichtert werden weil sie die hälfte
der sozialausgaben von der bundesagentur
für arbeit erstattet bekommen und das
kurzarbeitergeld soll über die
gesetzliche bezugsdauer hinaus auch bis
zu zwei jahre verlängert werden
ohne krise bewältigen so viel freiheit
wie möglich nicht mehr einschränkung als
nötig so der titel wenn ich
zusammenfassen was in den letzten wochen
passiert ist was die regierung so getan
hat um die sie tragenden parteien sage
ich zu spät gehandelt dann panisch
überzogen und dann zögerlich weiter
fortführen der situation am ersten 12 20
war es der erste in china bekannt wurde
haben andere länder den einsatz von
wärmebildkameras an flughäfen eingesetzt
und haben ist solange isolierstation
geschaffen und patienten gegebenenfalls
aufnehmen zu können
daraus folgte für uns für die afg als
erste fraktion im deutschen bundestag am
12.2 antrag bekämpfung der seuche
ausbreitung im flugverkehr ein
sechs-punkte-programm denen sie
logischerweise abgelehnt hatten wie
immer darin kam vor bereithalten von
ausreichendes wir bitten
impfstoffforschung durch den bund
forcieren nationale aufklärungskampagne
starten unter anderem unser gleichen
zeit stellen wird den antrag die
medikamentenproduktion von china nach
deutschland und europa zurück zu holen
weil wir auch da schon voraus zahlen
dieses großen problems rat das sehen sie
ihr jetzt mittlerweile auch es ist jetzt
bekannt dass die basis reputation
bereits am 22 23 und 1 lag und trotzdem
halten sie die einschränkungen der
freiheitsrechte und die einschränkung
bei die wirtschaft im wesentlichen
weiterhin aufrecht meine damen und
herren und haben damit billigend den
ruinen ganzer wirtschaftszweige kauf
genommen
sie haben besitzt keinen bildung eines
gremiums durchgeführt aus führenden
wissenschaftlern damit auch mal andere
meinung zu wort kommen
gestern bei der regierungsbefragung kam
zum ausdruck lieber vorsichtiges handeln
als irgendwelche risiko eingehen ja wenn
sie das wollen
vorsichtiges handeln dann hätten sie ja
nicht um sechs punkte plan zustimmen
können wir bauen die ersten dann hätten
sie vorsichtig gabelt und dann hätten
wir vielleicht solche auswirkungen haben
sie kapiert haben und da wir ja aber ich
kann ja teilweise auch verstehen wenn
sie natürlichen koalitionspartner hatten
oder haben so wird zum beispiel hier
vertreten durch einen hang haye gelingt
am 12.3 sagte in bezug auf eine rege
darf des corona die größte
herausforderung das gefährliche virus in
diesem land bei allen bedrohungen die
wir haben ist nicht korrupt
das ist der währung des hasses durch die
ard denn solche anträge solche reden die
zu verbreitet werden das ist viel
schlimmer da hat recht dass ich bei ihm
genauso ist sie setzen lieber die
gesundheit der bevölkerung spiel als
dass ich immer eine opposition noch mal
reden antwort stehen können also ganz
traurig oder hass und hetze in diesem
raum kommt von ihnen nicht von daher
stehen dann haben wir das schon mal
gemacht gucken sich bei ankunft wieder
reden meine damen und herren wir haben
im ausschuss für gesundheit die
schutzmaßnahmen mitgetragen
aber die fortführung von einschränkungen
dieser form halten wir für
unverantwortlich kein ende der
beschränkung des benannt wie sollen denn
die betriebe planen sie haben will k s
weiterhin vorprogrammiert er ist nicht
aufgehoben und meine damen und herren
nicht nachvollziehbar ist etwas und die
frau kollegin was krämer hat ja eben
gesagt besser vorbereiten wollen wir uns
ja so als hätten sie aber machen können
denn an
in 2012 gab es eine studie der
bundesregierung risikoanalyse im
bevölkerungsschutz 2012 können
vielleicht einige von ihnen
und da ist im auftrag der
bundesregierung ein szenario entwickelt
worden was haargenau auf die zeit der
großen krise passt denn hintergrund war
dieser analyse oder dieses szenario eins
in dieser virus verbreitet sich von
herzchen aus weit weltweit und dabei
geraten die gesundheitssysteme schnell
an ihre grenzen
genau passt mehr infizierte person
reisen ein die wir waren zu spät passt
auch meine damen und herren
genau das ist eingetreten die diao hat
zu spät gewarnt die wehr hat noch am 24
erst mal erklärt angesichts der bisher
vorliegenden informationen über die
swiss re die eu derzeit von reise- oder
handelsbeschränkungen für china hat dann
ist da wohl die kritik an der wwu
verständlich kommunizieren ist gar nicht
meine damen und herren wir forderungen
in unserem antrag das hotel gastronomie
betriebe handelsunternehmen unabhängig
von der größe und kulturbetrieb und
dienstleister unter beachtung von
ehemals war mieter tätig werden dürfen
wir fordern maßnahmen zum schutz
risikogruppen und die forschung
untersuchungen zu virus saß kurs 2
durchzuführen
wir fordern weiter das rkw und das
gemeinsame bundesausschuss
handlungsanweisungen für pflegeheimen
reha-einrichtungen pflegedienste
arbeitet und den schutz für bewohner
patienten personal gewährleisten zu
können
meine damen und herren dieses trios
dieses auswählen allein dass dieses wort
überhaupt in diesem lande keine genannt
wird fand ich für eine schande ist so
was sie hätten schon längst eine
vorbereitung machen kann dass diese
menschen geschützt werden
es gibt mittlerweile auch briefe von
bürgern in dieser altersgruppe sehen die
sich sehr sehr unsicher diesem land
fühlen meint herr kollege denken sie
bitte an die redezeit sind weit drüber
meine damen und herren letzte satz wir
möchten alle deutlichkeit sagen
grundrecht einschränkungen soll § 5 des
gesetzes zur bevölkerung über die
mission lage das kennen wir ja eine sind
klar zu befristen
es gibt für uns keine einschränkung der
grundrechte durch die hintertür
besonderen maßen an das leben hat meine
damen und herren
vielen dank der tab spangenberg war das
von der fdp-fraktion hat natürlich
gesprochen nicht zur weiterbildung
sondern zu einem anderen thema hat ich
habe mich verhört in dem was die
bundestagspräsident aufgerufen hat die
weiterbildung ist zusatzpunkt 13 der
wird im anschluss debattiert jetzt sind
wir bei tagesordnungspunkt 13 und das
ist ein afd antrag der dem spangenberger
den begründet die fdp die korona
beschränkungen unter anderem er sofort
aufheben und für gastronomie hotels
theater konzertsäle etc lockern so
schlimm
rudolf henke jetzt für die union liegt
mir nicht sicher ob daran schon also
ständig hat sich jetzt alles gut alles
ernst ja ich hab's nicht verfolgen so
frei wie möglich so höflich wie nötig
das war der spruch meines alten
lateinlehrer neun jahre latein der uns
immer gesagt hat wie man übersetzen muss
so frei wie möglich so wörtlich wie
nötig und deswegen ist mir erst mal die
überschrift des antrags den wir jetzt
hier diskutieren sehr sehr sympathisch
so viel freiheit wie möglich nicht mehr
einschränkungen als notwendig und wer
wollte dem widersprechen
aber was sich widerspricht liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die diesen
antrag einbringen ist doch was stimmt
denn jetzt also entweder war die
bundesregierung mit ihren entscheidungen
zu spät
entweder war sie zu zögerlich oder das
was sie jetzt vorschlagen ist unsinn
weil sie darin ja geradezu vorschlagen
für alle bereiche des wirtschaftlichen
und gesellschaftlichen handelns jetzt
die öffnungen zu ermöglichen und das
finde ich widerspricht sich total
denn sie sagen ja am anfang war tier
nicht vorsichtig genug und wir haben
gemahnt ihr müsstet vorsichtiger sein
sie kritisieren die
weltgesundheitsorganisation dafür nicht
vorsichtig genug gewesen zu sein
und jetzt sagen sie nachdem wir mit
aufwand und mühe
und übrigens ohne ihre zustimmung weil
hier im plenum haben sie sich enthalten
ohne ihre zustimmung die maßnahmen
beschlossen haben die jetzt gültig sind
nachdem wir damit zu einer
reproduktionsrate von 1,0 gekommen sind
sagen sie jetzt ihr müsst es früher
aufheben
was sagen sie ja die war vorher schon
wer wusste dass sie schlumberger
schlumberger von wann kommt denn die
mitteilung des rk ii
ich habe die cia das epidemiologische
butter des rk ii welches datum trägt das
siebzehnte april 2020 da stets doch drin
sind sie denn die hellseher
die das am 22 märz gewusst hätten dann
hätten sie sonst doch am 22 märz mal
sagen sollen haben sie aber nicht daran
als haben wir anstiege der
infektionsrate von 30 prozent am tag
gehabt damals waren wir bei einem erneut
von zwischen 2,6 und 3,8 und da sagen
sie jetzt weil sich später
herausgestellt hat dass die maßnahmen
die eingeleitet worden sind von der
bundesregierung und von den
bundesländern und die von uns gut
geheißen worden sind weil die eine
wirkung gehabt haben bis zum 22
märz kann man jetzt alles wieder
aufmachen das ist unverantwortlich weil
sie damit völlig vorbeigehen an der
notwendigkeit daten auch integriert und
wissenschaftlich seriös zu
interpretieren sie tun jetzt so als
hätte man hier sehen müssen als wäre es
so gewesen
erlauben sie eine spannende der
gespannten gab nochmal für die afg
vielen einfach präsidenten für ihre
kollegen
ich habe gesagt nachdem das nun bekannt
wahrheit die sie die maßnahmen trotzdem
aufrecht obwohl wir unter einsehen
deswegen brauchen wir diese maßnahmen
nicht mehr aufhalten das war mal die
rede
ich war nicht da hält sie ja das war
jetzt habe ich deutlich gesagt oder ich
habe mich falsch ausgedrückt das sage
ich nochmal jetzt wer hat das nicht mehr
nötig das ist ja dritte punkt erst
zögerlich dann übertrieben erst später
übertrieben und jetzt zögerlich so ist
es gesagt wurden und das bin ich nochmal
zu beachten vielen dank ich antworte
ihnen ja es ist system blendend
verstanden
ich antworte ihnen gerne und ich
erinnere an die lage von mitte märz
täglich das wachstum der infektion von
30 prozent bei einer fortsetzung dieser
dynamik hätten wir zu ostern eine
völlige überlastung aller
gesundheitlichen
versorgungseinrichtungen in deutschland
erlebt wir hätten zu ostern zehn
millionen infizierte und einen gänzlich
unerfüllbaren bedarf an infekt
intensivbetten 240.000 gehabt und diese
gefahr bleibt weil es ja jederzeit
wieder mit einer vergleichbaren dynamik
in bestimmten regionen oder auch
flächendeckend los gehen kann und lieber
herr spanien betten dort noch nicht
wahlberg sie selbst trauen ja ihren
eigenen worten nicht denn ihrem antrag
das schreiben sie ja neben dieser ganzen
öffne rey und öffne reihe und oft normal
und der produktionsrate 1 und wir müssen
uns keine sorgen mehr machen
da schreiben sie unter acht dass sie
fordern die getroffenen massnahmen
wöchentlich zu überprüfen
und der bundestag ist dabei in
angemessener weise zu beteiligen
werter herr kollege spangenberg wenn sie
das du wöchentlich überprüfen wollen wie
sehr trauen sie denn dann ihre eigenen
aussagen das wäre doch dann gar nicht
nötig sondern das ist doch nur nötig
weil sie sagen es kann total schief
gehen und dann muss man noch sagen mit
allem respekt und das ist der letzte
teil der antwort mit an respekt
wöchentliche überprüfung lieberherr
spangenberg wir haben eine
inkubationszeit die legt er über einer
woche als unter einer lösung
wir haben dann eine asymptomatische
erkrankungs phase an deren ende der
höhepunkt der infektiosität legt dann
kommen zum ersten mal symptome so dass
tests durchgeführt werden können und
diese tests werden dann auch noch mal
ein paar tage brauchen bis sie
ausgewertet sind und am ende dieser
tests beginnt dann der melde- verzug bis
wir es in den meldungen erleben und
deswegen brauchen sie eine längere
beobachtungszeit und zu beurteilen ob
eine maßnahme sich elitär und vertan
auswirkt oder nicht so jetzt die normale
rede weiter
diana schlangenberg bitte hänge so und
deswegen sage ich dass wir diese gefahr
von der sich selber ausgehen sonst wäre
keine rechtliche überprüfung der
maßnahmen nötig dass sie weiterhin
besteht dass wir das abwenden konnten
das ist eine riesengroße
gemeinschaftsleistung aller bürgerinnen
und bürger aller politisch
verantwortlichen im land von allen in
gesundheitsberufen aktiven aus der
wissenschaft aus den gesundheitsämtern
und natürlich verstehe ich das jetzt
eine rege debatte stattfindet aber
bitteschön welche konsequenz tragen sie
denn vor helgoland hat heute ihr
fraktionsvorsitzender vormittag hier
gesagt ich zitiere ihn die
quarantänemaßnahmen laufen längst selbst
sie hat der staat ist dabei weitgehend
überflüssig
es wird also zeit die beschränkung der
grundrechte zu lockern und die
schutzmaßnahmen in die private
verantwortung der bürger zu überführen
das heißt es ja das heißt auch nach
ihrem applaus jetzt dass das was wir
hier alles beraten jeden vorschlag jede
kontroverse dass sie das für überflüssig
erklären und dass sie sagen der staat
hat da gar keine funktion dem
widerspreche ist ausdrücklich das halte
ich für ein taschenspieler tun und sie
glauben dass auch nicht selbst und sie
tragen diesen antrag nicht deswegen hier
vor weil sie das virus eindämmen wollen
sondern weil sie die afd ausbreiten
wollen und weil sie dazu jeden unmut in
der bevölkerung nutzen möchten um
identifikation zu erzeugen und deswegen
finde ich ist das eine art von
auseinandersetzung die ich einfach nicht
billigen und gutheißen kann
und natürlich haben wir eine situation
einer regen politischen diskussion das
ist gut so sowohl die leopoldina als
auch experten der helmholtz gemeinschaft
haben systematisch epidemiologische
analysen der bevölkerung gefordert und
wir befürworten ein infektions
monitoring als entscheidungs- und
bewertungsgrundlage wenn sie mich fragen
als arzt dann sage ich ich wünsche mir
ein dashboard mit den wichtigsten
relevanten daten möglichst in echtzeit
zu realitäts und tages nah wie möglich
neuinfektionen verdopplung zeit
reproduktionsrate todesfälle verfügbaren
betten intensiv plätze über
sterblichkeit beatmungs plätze menschen
in häuslicher oder institutioneller
isolation oder quarantäne
aktion zur nachverfolgbarkeit
bewegungsdaten und und und aber sie
gaukeln eine falsche sicherheit vor wenn
sie daraus profit schlagen wollen zu
sagen wir öffnen jetzt einfach und haben
dabei keine sorgen
und das finde ich darf auch nicht
passieren und wenn sie als kronzeugen
den präsidenten der bundesärztekammer
zitieren dann zitiere ich daraus was er
mir geschrieben hat da sagt er nämlich
dass eine rein politisch bzw ökologisch
motivierte sofortige wiederherstellung
weiter teile des öffentlichen lebens wie
sie derzeit von verschiedenen seiten
gefordert wird aus ärztlicher sicht
nicht verantwortbar ist das ist die
antwort der bundesärztekammer zu diesem
thema kommen sie jetzt bitte zum schluss
ich komme zum schluss war es natürlich
auch dass arbeitslosigkeit armut
überforderung repression und angst krank
machen können und auch darauf muss man
achten wirtschaft und gesundheit sind
keine gegensätze
und manch einer müsste vielleicht klarer
sagen nach welchem monitoringsystem man
sich richten soll
aber bei ihnen sehe ich nur den rückzug
der staatlichen verantwortung und nicht
hinterlegt eröffnungs forderung ohne
garantie für den gesundheitsschutz der
beteiligten
das kann ich nicht billigen und deswegen
bin ich sehr dafür dass das parlament
den von ihnen gestellten antrag
sorgfältig berät aber dann ablehnt
herzlichen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
schenke war das für evolution und er ist
präsident der ärztekammer nordrhein und
hatte sich zu beginn seiner rede richtig
in rage geredet angesichts des afg
antrag der grundlage dieser debatte ist
und ein angesichts der äußerungen der
afg auch heute verlaufe des tages was
die lockerung der beschränkungen
anbelangt
und ich weiß wovon ich spreche weil wir
sehr intensiv und sehr gut und sehr
kooperativ und konstruktiv in der
mitarbeiter mitarbeiterinnen kommission
zusammengearbeitet haben und deswegen
ist es die wehmut und gleichzeitig hoffe
ich wie für sie dass sie diesen schritt
nicht schrecklich freuen wenn sie
natürlich tun sondern dass sie eine gute
zukunft vor sich haben und wir werden
sie nicht vergessen der nächste reden
dafür die fdp fraktion sagte stefan
ruppert stefan ruppert für die fdp schon
angekündigt seine letzte rede
präsidentin meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren ganz herzlichen dank für die
wertschätzenden worte die ich genauso
auch zurückgeben kann
lassen sie mich in meiner letzten rede
vielleicht nur einen satz zum
vorliegenden antrag sagen wir haben
einen moment einer großen krise erlebt
und hier wie im alltag offenbaren sich
dann politische charaktere
es gibt die einen die wollen
verantwortung im moment der krise
übernehmen auch eine opposition macht
sich gedanken wollen wir da nicht
gemeinsam ein signal der geschlossenheit
in der akuten situation geben und
übernimmt verantwortung wohl wissen dass
ihre aufgabe langfristig die kritik der
regierung ist und es gibt hier
fraktionen die haben diese verantwortung
übernommen auch aus der opposition
sie haben sie nicht übernommen sondern
sie lauern auf den moment wo sie bei
solchen dingen immer vorkommende fehler
kritisieren können das offenbart ihren
charakter und ihre politische qualität
vielen dank
auf dauer braucht es die legislative um
krisen zu bewältigen sie ist am puls der
bevölkerung sie kriegt die impulse und
nimmt sie wahr und spiegelt sie ihnen
das parlament und in die gesetzgebung
zurück pluralität ist die voraussetzung
zur farbe zur bewältigung von krisen
es darf in solchen momenten kein wort
der alternativlosigkeit des einen
einzigen richtigen weges geben ein wort
wie ein wort für alternativlos kommt im
liberalen sprachschatz der immer auch
die meinung des andersdenkenden
respektiert nicht vor
oder hans dietrich genscher ist einmal
so ausgedrückt zu einem immer neuen
gespräch zu einer immer neuen diskussion
gibt es keine alternative die es also
die einzige verwendung dieses wort ich
finde wir brauchen und wir haben einen
handlungsfähigen staat in deutschland
aber wir brauchen eine starke
bürgergesellschaft freiheit wird nicht
von der tribüne verteidigt und insofern
muss jeder einzelne verantwortung
übernehmen das ist unser liberales
menschenbild verantwortung und freiheit
gehen hand in hand dafür kämpfen wir
dafür habe ich mich immer politisch
eingesetzt und werde das auch wieder
ehrenamtlich tun
wir werden diese krise nicht bewältigen
ohne vertrauen in jeden einzelnen
ich habe bei meinen kindern meinen
doktoranden meinen mitarbeitern immer
erlebt vertraue den menschen sie werden
es dir danken dann werden sie
verantwortung übernehmen dann werden sie
das beste aus sich machen und dann
werden sie auch krisen und schwierige
situationen bewältigen ein staat setzt
rahmenbedingungen aber jeder einzelne
von uns übernimmt verantwortung und für
sich selbst aber auch für andere und so
bewältigen wir eine krise die soziale
marktwirtschaft bürgerrechte
freiheit gehören untrennbar zusammen die
empirie unserer geschichte zeigt immer
dann wenn wir eines dieser elemente
zurückgelassen haben
das haben wir schiffbruch erlitten
deswegen ein klares plädoyer für die
soziale marktwirtschaft zu dem übrigens
auch friseure gehören die man dieser
tage merkt aber für die soziale
marktwirtschaft für freiheit und
bürgerrechte dafür kämpfen wir und viele
andere in diesem haus lassen sie mich am
ende ein zitat das meine eltern mir aus
einer predigt neulich mitgegeben haben
in leicht abgeänderter form zitieren
humor gelassenheit und zuversicht sind
die kamele die uns durch die wüste
tragen stolz und vor allem mit
dankbarkeit habe ich diesem haus
angehört wir haben ein großartiges
parlament ein kahles meinungsbild dafür
bin ich unendlich dankbar wir leben in
toller verfassung und deswegen müssen
wir in der krise nicht bange ihnen alles
gute und gottes segen vielen dank stefan
ruppert für die liberalen mit seiner
letzten rede er verlässt die politik das
hatte er schon angekündigt wird sein
bundestagsmandat niederlegen er ist
übrigens auch vorsitzender der
herzlichen fdp auch dieses antworte
abgeben und wechselt beruflich in den
vorstand der braun melsungen ag das ist
ein farmer medizinbedarf und bekommt
hier deswegen auch von gesamten haus den
beifall und hören ist das gesamte haus
wünscht ihnen alles gute
auch für den neuen lebensabschnitt und
persönlich sage ich auch danke für die
zusammenarbeit in unterschiedlichsten
zusammenhängen und gerade zu den themen
über die sie gerade hier auch gesprochen
haben alles auf peter paul die jetzt die
sitzungsleitung hier von claudia roth
übernommen hat als
bundestagsvizepräsidentin
nochmal mit den besten wünschen für den
weiteren lebensweg und jetzt geht es
aber weiter in der debatte mit johann
saathoff für die spd fraktion sehr
geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich will mehr als nur einen satz zu dem
antrag sagen aber nicht weil er von der
inhalt her so viel bestand hat sondern
weil es ein stück weit auch ihr weltbild
widerspiegelt dem vorliegenden antrag
ist zu entnehmen dass die maßnahmen zur
eindämmung der korona pandemie jetzt auf
genug aufgehoben werden können und ich
frag mich beim lesen des antrags aus
sicht der ard
denn die party schon vorbei ist dazu
steht in ihrem antrag nichts gibt es
vielleicht auf der rechten seite des
parlaments grundsätzlich neue
erkenntnisse von denen wir bisher noch
nichts gehört haben in ihrem antrag
finde ich jedenfalls dazu nichts
wir stellen an dieser stelle mal fest
wir wissen erst sehr sehr wenig über das
virus sie auch sie wissen fast nichts
darüber machen aber populäre vorschläge
und das geht aus meiner sicht überhaupt
gar nicht ich hatte jeden das gespräch
sofort zu beenden wenn jemand vor ihnen
sitzt der den anschein erweckt er wirst
du bereits alles über das virus und
wusste auch was zu tun ist
beenden sie das gespräch das lohnt sich
nicht so einen menschen gibt es auf der
ganzen erde nicht auch nicht in der
armee fraktion
was wir was wir allerdings wissen ist
dass wir erst am anfang der pandemie
stehen circa zwei bis drei prozent der
bevölkerung haben erst antikörper und
selbst das ist nicht sicher was wir
wissen ist dass die überwiegende
mehrheit der menschen sich an die regeln
hält und sie für sinnvoll er stellt
wir haben alle menschen zu hause in
unseren familien in unserem
bekanntenkreis dieser risikogruppe
angehören und die wir nicht verlieren
was wir wissen ist dass die folge einer
lockerung so wie sie das vorschlagen am
ende erst in 14 tagen sichtbar oder in
leichen zählbar sein würde und von daher
völlig unverantwortlich sich als unser
aus unserer sicht darstellt wer jetzt
großflächig öffnungen fordert den
menschen vor macht es könnte bereits
jetzt alles wieder so sein wie es vor
der krise einmal war er spielt nicht nur
mit dem feuer
er stellt auch alle bisherigen
öffentlichen und privaten investitionen
ins feuer und handelt damit aus meiner
sicht zutiefst unverantwortlich
sie behaupten dass die menschen erwarten
dass die sanktionen umgehend gelockert
werden auch ich nehme fragen nach
lockerung war überhaupt kein thema aber
ich erlebe auch ein hohes maß an
verständnis und solidarität der menschen
und bin dankbar dafür
vielleicht ist im ländlichen raum alles
besser als da wo sie leben aber ich
erlebe menschen die privat organisieren
und soziale medien für wirklich soziale
zwecke plötzlich nutzen sie kaufen für
menschen ein deren risiko zu groß wäre
einzukaufen
davon steht in ihrem einfach nichts ich
erlebe kinder in ostfriesland die malen
karten oder schreiben briefe für
menschen in altenheimen und versüßen
diesen den tag damit ich höre von ihre
von dieser solidarität in ihrem antrag
gar nichts
und wenn ich mir aber ertragen gucke da
lese ich sie sind dafür die grenzen zu
schließen das überrascht jetzt nicht
aber eine öffnung für erntehelfer damit
sie noch spargel auf den tellern finden
sie okay unter welchen umständen die
arbeiten und leben müssen völlig egal
hauptsache der spargel wird gestochen
das zeigt meine damen und herren das
zeigt ihr menschenbild dessen wert aus
ihrer sicht im wesentlichen von der
nationalität abhängt dafür tun sie mir
leid
die pandemie ist nicht national zu
bewältigen sondern im gegenteil nur mit
internationaler solidarität rolf
mützenich hat heute vormittag
eindrucksvoll daraufhin
diesen da sollten wir in europa anfangen
wir müssen die forschungskooperation
noch mehr stärken und wir brauchen einen
fond für katastrophen das vertrauen in
europa und dessen lösungskompetenz muss
gestärkt werden wir müssen unseren
beitrag leisten für stärkeres vertrauen
der länder untereinander auch
deutschland gegenüber
in europa die man die pandemie liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen legt fehler in
der vergangenheit offen
da gibt es gar keine frage wir sollten
sie jetzt aber nicht skandalisieren zum
eigenen politischen zweck sondern daraus
lernen zum beispiel sollten wir lernen
dass wir falsche anreize und
gesundheitssystem gesetzt haben
konkurrenzdruck und preis sollten dort
nicht priorität haben sonst hätten wir
jetzt mehr schutzausrüstung
zum beispiel sollten wir lernen dass
unsere lieferketten oftmals fragil sind
kein politischer aber eigentlich ein
managementfehler wenn man so will das
lieferketten gesetz sorgt schon eine
verantwortliche und verantwortbare
lieferkette wenn das management das
nicht selber machen könnte und es wird
zeit dass wir das bekommen
es geht aber nicht nur um lieferketten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wenn wir
aus deutschland uns nicht solidarisch
zeigen mit anderen ländern in europa
dieses teils härter getroffen hat dann
brechen uns nicht nur die lieferketten
denkt sondern dann brechen uns auch
sämtliche absatzmärkte weg und wenn wir
also nicht aus solidarität und aus
mitgefühl und aus menschlichkeit unseren
nachbarn helfen wollen dann sollten wir
es wenigstens als wirtschaftlicher
notwendigkeit erkennen
ihr plan ist grenzen zu und legen auf
meine bewertung dazu plakativer
populismus was wir tun müssen ist
hilfsmaßnahmen weiter entwickeln
insbesondere für bereiche die länger von
den schließungen betroffen sind wie zum
beispiel die tourismuswirtschaft was wir
tun müssen ist uns um die familien
kümmern das kindeswohl darf nicht auf
den spiel gesetzt werden notwendigkeit
ist dafür eine kindergrundsicherung das
wird uns doch in diesen tagen deutlicher
denn je
was wir tun müssen ist die
privatisierung der daseinsvorsorge noch
einmal kritisch hinterfragen liebe
liberalen freunde
es zeigt sich nämlich dass auf den
reinen markt eben kein verlass ist
jedenfalls verlassen sich lieber auf
kommunen und wir müssen in die zukunft
investieren und wir müssen die
arbeitnehmer und azubis im blick haben
um ihnen durch diese krise zu helfen in
ostfriesland sagt man sind netto hätten
weit es nicht wert der den verlegenheit
kommt wir sozialdemokraten wissen und zu
helfen mit abstand mit anstand und mit
verstand herzlichen dank das wort hat dr
andré hahn für die fraktion die linke
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
gestatten sie mir zu beginn den muslimen
in deutschland zum heute beginnenden
ramadan die besten wünsche zu
übermitteln
das verbinde ich mit dem dank dafür dass
sich die muslime seit beginn der korona
krise hier genauso solidarisch wie
andere religionsgemeinschaften verhalten
haben
sie haben sich solidarisch verhalten sie
haben ihre moscheen und gebetsräume
geschlossen gehalten und das in dem für
sie so wichtigen fastenmonat ramadan in
dem das allabendliche gemeinsame
fastenbrechen ein ganz zentrales element
ist also dafür herzlichen dank kurz kurz
zum antrag der afd
die korona krise ist ohne zweifel eine
globale herausforderung
um sie zu bewältigen braucht das
vernunft verstand und solidarität die
afg hat nichts davon aufzuweisen
der antrag ist ein sammelsurium von
teils abstrusen forderungen und dabei
plump eingeflochten der deutschtümelei
dazu gehört die forderung mit bezug auf
die eu notstands klausel die grenzen für
schutzsuchende zu schließen und sie in
quarantäne lagern zu sanieren das gibt
die notstands klausel gar nicht her und
dass es politisch wie epidemiologisch
unfug und das offene grenzen für die afg
ein gräuel sind ist nichts neues
als abgeordneter aus dem landkreis
sächsische schweiz osterzgebirge weiß
ich aber nur zu genau wie viele
krankenhäuser und arztpraxen bedroht
wären wenn das personal aus tschechien
nicht mehr zur arbeit kommen würde
und natürlich ist es die aufgabe des
parlaments das regierungshandeln bei der
bekämpfung der korona krise kritisch zu
begleiten
einschränkungen an bürger und
freiheitsrechten hinsichtlich ihrer
angemessenheit und wirkungen zu
hinterfragen und eigene vorschläge
dagegen zu setzen
deshalb hat meine fraktion die linke
allein in dieser sitzungswoche 18
anträge in den bundestag eingebracht
und fakt ist im namen des
infektionsschutz sind in deutschland
seit über 1
monat zahlreiche grundrechte massiv
eingeschränkt auch grundrechte die für
eine demokratische gesellschaft
konstituieren sind wie etwa die
versammlungsfreiheit
zweifellos ist der angegebene zweck die
pandemie einzudämmen legitim
der entzug von grund und
freiheitsrechten auf längere sicht ist
für eine demokratie nicht hinnehmbar die
behörden sind verpflichtet nach
möglichkeiten mildere mittel zu wählen
um die versammlungsfreiheit zu sichern
und die umsetzung ist vielerorts
fragwürdig und ich finde es darf nicht
zur regel werden dass man erst das
verfassungsgericht anrufen muss um
friedlich und unter einhaltung der
abstand gebote demonstrieren zu können
deshalb fordern wir von bund und ländern
dass alle verordnungen
allgemeinverfügungen revidiert werden
die ein pauschales oder
unverhältnismässig weitgehendes verbot
von versammlungen nach artikel 8
grundgesetz beinhalten für uns als linke
für uns als linke steht jedenfalls fest
das grundrecht auf versammlungsfreiheit
darf auch in zeiten wie diesen nicht zur
disposition gestellt werden wir alle
haben eine gemeinsame verantwortung dass
aus der korona krise nicht auch noch
eine krise der demokratie entsteht
herzlichen dank der linksfraktion die
vorletzte rednerin in dieser debatte zum
antrag der af dafür über lockerungen der
korona beschränkungen kommt von den
grünen kirsten kaputt konter die
sprecherin für gesundheitsförderung
ihrer fraktion
und wie alle wartet sie noch bis das
blut des infiziert wurde
frau kollegin liebe damen und herren
liebe kolleginnen kollegen stellen sie
sich vor sie sind in einem flugzeug das
flugzeug stürzt ab sie haben glück im
unglück sie haben einen fallschirm dabei
sie setzten ihn auf öffnet ihnen der sr
fallschirm verringert den fall und
mitten im flug werfen sie diesen
fallschirm ab und sagen super maßnahme
hat geklappt jetzt kaufe ich sie nicht
mehr wer würde das tun
es wundert uns gar nicht das von ganz
rechts hier im parlament wieder
unausgegorene und wirklich
menschenfeindliche vorschläge gekommen
sie also wollen quasi alle
schutzmaßnahmen sofort aussetzen und
damit die exponentielle ausbreitung des
virus cupid 19 sehenden auges in kauf
nehmen das ist verantwortungslos
wer die gefahr dieses virus unterschätzt
der gefährdet leben gut dass in diesem
land weder im bund noch in den ländern
nirgendwo verantwortung tragen
sie wollen also konto wieder alles auf
normalbetrieb umstellen mit einer
ausnahme die grenzen sollen nach meinung
der nationalisten geschlossen bleiben
dauerhaft den antrag der afg kann man
nicht anders lesen als wenn deutschen
deutsche infizieren ist das virus nicht
so schlimm
das ist zynisch meine damen und herren
was die hier vorgetragen
das sind alles verwechslungen wir in
bremen sagen dazu die verwechslung von
gustav mit gasthof und das war dass die
ganze zeit was wir stattdessen jetzt
brauchen ist eine vernünftige und eine
sorgfältige strategie die step by step
die rückkehr in den alltag ermöglicht
und gleichzeitig weiterhin die
infektionsgefahren reduziert so lange es
kein impfstoff und keine wirksame
therapie gegen kuwait 19 gibt wird das
risiko der ansteckung hoch bleiben
und genau wie trump wollen sie die
mittel für die whu sogar kürzen
wir werden aber die globale
gesundheitspolitische zusammenarbeit
verstärken müssen denn nur ein
internationales abgestimmtes und
solidarisches zusammenwirken kann die
gefahr von pandemien
mit der können wir die gefahr von
pandemien begegnen wir wissen dass es im
krisen sehr schnell zu einer sehnsucht
nach autorität kombi kinder sehen wir
uns nach einem starken elternteil weiß
alles wieder gut macht doch ein
überbietungswettbewerb bei autoritären
maßnahme ist falsch und genau so falsch
ist ein überbietungswettbewerb bei den
aufhebung der notwendigen
schutzmaßnahmen es ist ein dilemma ja
das virus ist gefährlich die isolation
ist es auch aber diesem dilemma werden
wir nur durch sorgfalt begegnen können
markige sprüche wie helfen nicht weiter
die sind sogar gefährlich wie wir heute
gesehen haben
abschließend in der psychotherapie gibt
es eine sehr schöne übung wir stellen
uns vor wie wir in fünf jahren auf diese
krise zurück blicken ich wünsche mir wir
wünschen uns dass wir dann auf
gegenseitige auf anhaltende solidarität
schauen und den fall für eben nicht zu
früh abgelegt haben werden
dankeschön
unter war warnte vor einem
überbietungswettbewerb in beide
richtungen letzter redner in dieser
debatte zum antrag der afg kommt jetzt
von der cdu csu fraktion stefan
pischinger sitzt für seine fraktion im
gesundheitsausschuss das wort hat der
kollege stefan bissinger für die cdu csu
fort herr präsident meine damen und
herren in den vergangenen wochen und
monaten dieser krise haben die menschen
in unserem land unter beweis gestellt
dass wir als gesellschaft dazu in der
lage sind füreinander einzutreten
gemeinsam entschlossen und solidarisch
an dieser stelle möchte ich zunächst
ausdrücklich den einsatz und das
unermüdliche engagement der
beschäftigten unserem gesundheitswesen
hervorheben sie leisten in diesen tagen
beispielloses und verdienen unseren
respekt unsere anerkennung und vor allem
unsere unterstützung
neben mein bundestagsmandat bin ich
weiter in der satz tätig über die
zurückliegenden wochen konnte ich mir
also selbst ein bild machen mit welch
außergewöhnlichen einsatz sich alle
beteiligten vor ort um die erkrankten
kümmern
und ich bin überzeugt ohne unser
hervorragend funktionierendes netz von
ambulanten praxen wären die
krankenhäuser innerhalb kürzester zeit
an ihre belastungsgrenzen gestoßen
im gegensatz zu anderen ländern können
hierzulande sechs von sieben patienten
ambulant versorgt werden
das ist ein entscheidender vorteil
jetzt ist auch dem einsatz jeder
einzelnen praxis und deutschland mit
ihren ärzten medizinischen
fachangestellten büro und
reinigungskräften zu verdanken dass wir
immer noch über ausreichend kapazitäten
in unseren krankenhäusern verfügen
ganz besonders im umgang mit dieser
weltweiten krise zeigt sich für mich
dass wir tatsächlich eines der besten
gesundheitssysteme dieser welt haben
und das sehen wir nicht nur wenn wir auf
den bereich der ambulanten versorgung
schauen das sehen wir auch daran dass
wir es innerhalb kürzester zeit
geschafft haben unsere intensiv und
beratungskapazitäten in den kliniken
entscheidend zu erhöhen
das sehen wir aber auch an der anzahl
der proben die unsere labore jeden tag
auf das virus testen und das sehen wir
im engagement der apotheken vor ort und
dem unermüdlichen einsatz unserer
forscherinnen und forscher diesen
menschen gilt heute mein ausdrücklicher
dank zu selten aber entscheidend ist ein
weiterer aspekt der gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalt erlaubt uns mit zuversicht
in die zukunft zu schauen denn gemeinsam
können wir diese krise überwinden dazu
brauchen wir aber auch in den kommenden
wochen die unterstützung jedes einzelnen
geben sie also weiterhin aufeinander
acht und vermeiden sie man immer möglich
die physische nähe zu anderen denn so
können wir erreichen dass die bisherigen
erfolge zur abflachung der ausbreitung
kurve auch nachhaltig sind die in den
vergangenen wochen erlassenen
handlungsempfehlungen und verhaltens
vorgaben haben sich als sehr
wirkungsvoll erwiesen und werden von
bund und ländern regelmäßig kritisch
überprüft und nach möglichkeiten
angepasst und das zeigt sich auch im
besonderen umgang mit der schrittweisen
lockerung einiger maßnahmen mit ihrem
vorliegenden antrag möchte sich nun auch
die fraktionen der afd in die debatte um
eine aufhebung geltender maßnahmen
einbringen grundsätzlich ist es ja zu
begrüßen im konkreten fall aber leider
handwerklich einfach schlecht gemacht
zuallererst die regelung die sie hier
einfordern kann der bund überhaupt nicht
erlassen scheinbar fehlt ihnen das
nötige grundverständnis der firma
strukturen unseres staates denn
zuständig sind in diesem fall laut
infektionsschutzgesetz die länder und
die entscheidungshoheit der länder ist
hier auch durchaus sinnvoll
nicht überall in der bundesrepublik ist
das infektionsgeschehen gleich
ausgeprägt auch die ergriffene maßnahmen
können daher nicht in jedem bundesland
gleich sein
zudem wurde ein großteil der maßnahmen
die sie in ihrem antrag einfordern
bereits in enger abstimmung mit der
bundesregierung durch die länder
ergriffen
insofern leistet die antrag aus meiner
sicht keinen gewinn bringenden beitrag
zur derzeitigen debatte um eine wirksame
und nachhaltige eindämmung der infektion
vielmehr müssen wir nun weiteren daran
arbeiten die geltenden einschränkungen
in kleinen schritten zurückzunehmen und
die auswirkung dabei jeweils genauestens
zu überprüfen
nur so können wir auch in zukunft die
gesundheit der bürgerinnen und bürger in
unserem land bestmöglich schützen vielen
dank ich schließe die aussprache wir
kommen zur abstimmung über den antrag
der fraktion der afc auf drucksache 18
1738 mit dem titel coruna krise
bewältigen so viel freiheit wie möglich
nicht mehr einschränkungen als nötig
dass die lockerungen für gastronomie
hotels gotteshäuser et cetera wieder
gelockert werden das allerdings dabei
hier gehen und abstandsregeln
eingehalten wird
die linke fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
gegen die stimmen der fdp abgelehnt